every scientist who we had talked to
said don't even try as you've got to get
a zodiac to land on the beach then hi 40
pieces of heavy equipment down the beach
across this river then down more beach
into the Ranger's Shack in 98 degree
temperatures
hopefully defined the leatherback turtle
that came to shore after a six thousand
mile journey to lay eggs all in the
middle of nowhere warm WA is where a
group of leatherback mothers will come
and lay their eggs and they travel 6,500
to 7,000 miles to the coast of Northern
California and Oregon and then they
don't return until they're about 15
years old and this is the same Beach
that they themselves were born and sure
enough we got to shore after six or
seven trips without capsizing without
any kind of disaster
you know we don't travel lightly so we
had a substantial amount of gear and so
we started trekking down the beach
carrying individual loads of 70 to 80
pounds we got down halfway and there's a
river and you can walk across the river
carrying your equipment above your head
but you have a risk of getting eaten by
a crocodile we thought Oh cross river is
not that bad you know we'll have you
know some big boats to get it across the
river well here comes these two little
canoes and it's being captained by a 10
year old boy no thinking you got across
the river and these very small canoe
Sam is rethinking his career choice
all of a sudden law school looks pretty
easy
and so we get down there of course you
know there's no rest for the wicked so
immediately set up we finished maybe at
8 o'clock at night everybody was just
completely like and so we go to sleep on
the floor of this ramshackle cabin you
never knew when you're near that call
that a leatherback turtle that come up
on shore to lay eggs it could have been
15 minutes from now it could be 6 hours
from now so 1 o'clock in the morning we
get the word our prayers were answered
there's a turtle we grab the bare
essentials can't we hike the gear down
all with Red Lanterns the reason we had
to use the red lights it's because a
turtle if he sees white light he'll turn
around and go back out because they'll
think Suns coming and they only do it in
the nighttime I was flabbergasted this
thing was so giant huge huge animal and
she was laying her eggs leatherback will
go into a trance when she's laying eggs
where you can then approach her and you
won't disturb her cycle and she'll lay
eggs then cover it up with sand and then
go back in the water after my two and a
half hours of filming you got it done
very very big sense of accomplishment
we also wanted to get some shots of
these young hatchlings going back in the
water because it's pretty unique
this massive huge 650 pound turtle when
he's hatched he's about that big the
scientists that they have to imprint
with the beach turtle just flap and a
flap it down and they're facing these
huge waves there must have been six to
eight foot waves coming in that day
getting hit by wave rolling back up then
they start walking back down again
seeing the first one get off Nick and
his life is started
we finally got everything back on the
boat there less than 24 hours our being
on this island and you forgot all the
pain you forgot all the stuff and you
forgot about the insects that night you
forgot about the lack of sleep because
we actually got this shot and we came
back with some incredible footage of
this leatherback turtle it was beautiful